tenemos que fx es igual al valor
absoluto de x + 2 y queremos evaluar la
integral definida desde menos 4 hasta 0
de fx de x y como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y vea si pueden resolver esto
ahora cuando hagan esto por primera vez
podrían tropezar un poco ya que como
sacamos un anti derivada de una función
con valor absoluto y la clave aquí es
volver a escribir
efe de x sin el valor absoluto y podemos
hacer eso reescribiendo a efe como una
función por partes y la manera en la que
voy a hacer esto es pensar en el
intervalo donde lo que sea que tomemos
dentro del valor absoluto sea positivo y
en el intervalo donde todo lo que
tomemos dentro del valor absoluto sea
negativo y el punto en el cual cambiamos
de ser positivos a negativos es donde x
+ 2 es igual a cero o dicho otra manera
donde x es igual a menos 2 entonces
pensemos en los intervalos donde x sea
menor que menos 2 y donde x sea mayor o
igual a menos 2
esto podría haber sido menor que igual
en cuyo caso este trabajo d habría sido
mayor que pero de cualquier manera
habría sido igual a este valor absoluto
ya que es una función continua bien
empecemos por el caso fácil el caso
fácil es pensar que es lo que pasa
cuando x es mayor o igual a menos 2
entonces observa que x + 2 va a ser
positivo o más bien va a ser mayor o
igual a 0 y entonces el valor absoluto
de eso va a ser ese mismo valor es decir
x + 2 por lo tanto será x + 2 cuando x
sea mayor o igual a menos 2 y que en el
otro caso cuando x es menor que menos 2
bien cuando x es menor que menos 2 x más
2 va a ser negativo y luego si sacan el
valor absoluto de un número negativo van
a sacar lo opuesto entonces va a ser
menos x más 2 en paréntesis y para
realmente entender esto porque
sinceramente es la parte más difícil de
todo el ejercicio de todo lo que estamos
haciendo
de hecho en realidad esto es más álgebra
que cálculo permítanme dibujar la
función de valor absoluto
para hacerlo más claro entonces por aquí
va a estar mi eje x y este de por acá va
a ser mi eje y digamos que aquí están x
igual a menos 2 y cuando estamos menor
que menos dos cuando x es menor que
menos 2 y gráfica se va a ver así y
cuando somos mayores que menos 2
entonces en otro color voy a poner que
la gráfica se va a ver así observa la
gráfica de color azul es la gráfica de x
+ 2 podemos decir que es la gráfica de
ye igual a x + 2 y esta otra gráfica de
aquí de color magenta es la gráfica de
menos x menos 2 y observa tiene
pendiente negativa e ínter secamos al
eje y en menos 2 y tiene bastante
sentido con lo que tenemos ahora una vez
que separamos esto podemos también
separar la integral podemos decir que lo
que escribimos aquí va a ser igual a amd
y bueno
tomemos esta integral y vamos a separar
la primero me voy a tomar la integral
de menos 42 de fx que en este caso serán
menos x menos observa lo único que hice
fue distribuir el signo aquí por de x ya
esto le vamos a sumar la integral de
menos 2 a 0 de x2 de x
y solamente para que lo tengas mucho más
claro vamos a ver lo que estamos
haciendo aquí sí aquí tenemos al menos
cuatro y por acá tenemos al cero esta
primera integral va a darnos esta área
de aquí que es el área bajo la curva de
menos x menos 2 bajo la curva o más bien
bajo esta recta y sobre el eje x y la
segunda integral nos va a dar esta otra
área de aquí entre x más 2 y el eje x
claro de menos 2 a 0 así que vamos a
evaluar cada uno de estos de hecho
inclusive podrían evaluarlo un poco con
área de triángulos pero vamos a hacerlo
analíticamente o algebraica mente para
ver qué es lo que está sucediendo ok
pensemos cuál es la anti derivada de
menos x bueno esto es muy fácil eso es
menos equis cuadrada entre 2 y después
tenemos este menos 2 el cual es la
derivada de menos 2x y vamos a evaluar
esto en menos 2
en -4 ok vamos a hacerle una vez esta
parte va a ser me queda menos 2 elevado
al cuadrado entre 2 que es menos 4
medios ya esto le vamos a quitar 2 x
menos 2 lo cual es 4 positivo entonces
esta es la evaluación en menos 2 y ahora
vamos a evaluarlo en menos 4 que me
quedarían me queda menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado
bueno hechos menos 16 menos 16 entre dos
menos 2 x menos 4 y eso es 8 positivo
más 8 entonces que va a darnos esto
bajemos un poco la pantalla para seguir
con este ejercicio y me queda que este
de aquí va a ser menos 2 y este de aquí
es menos 8
de hecho observa el segundo término va a
ser igual a 0 lo hice bien 4 al cuadrado
aquí tengo el signo negativo entre 28 y
luego tengo si más 8 entonces este
segundo término va a ser cero perfecto y
que me va a quedar en este 1er
bueno tengo menos dos más cuatro lo cual
va a ser igual a dos entonces lo que
tenemos aquí en magenta todo esto va a
ser igual a 2 y ahora vamos a pensar en
lo que tenemos acá en azul veamos la
anti derivada de x es x cuadrada entre 2
más y bueno aquí tengo más 2x y lo vamos
a evaluar en 0 y en menos 2 primero
vamos a evaluarlo en cero
bueno observa si lo evaluamos en cero
sólo va a ser cero así que a eso le
vamos a restar la evaluación en menos
dos y me quedaría menos 2 esto elevado
al cuadrado entre 2 pero eso es 4 medios
que al final es 2 positivos y luego
tengo 2 x menos 2 entonces eso es menos
4 entonces todo esto es menos 2 y aquí
tengo un signo negativo entonces sería
menos menos 2 o simplemente 2 positivo
entonces todo esto se reduce a la suma
de 2 más 2 y tiene sentido
tenemos aquí observan es 2 y toda esta
área que tenemos acá también es 2 porque
hay una simetría aquí y si los sumamos
vamos a tener que nuestra integral va a
ser igual a 4 y estoy seguro que con una
visión realista y un poco geométrica me
puedes decir mira la altura de aquí es 2
la base es 2 2 x 2 entre 2 es igual a 2
y lo mismo aquí porque otra vez tenemos
el argumento de esta simetría geométrica
y por lo tanto estas dos áreas son 2 la
sumamos y tenemos 4